es gibt einen neuen grenzwert einen
neuen richtwert der jetzt über unser
aller leben ja entscheidet der sich
danach richtet wie viele menschen im
krankenhaus mit corona landen und es ist
nicht ganz einfach das alles auseinander
zu klar sein wann gilt 2 gewann gilt
zweig plus für uns im studio ist jetzt
für den fiat auf er wird hier ein
bisschen klarheit rein bringen philipp
erklären sie einmal was ist der neue
wert hospitalisierung since i dance was
bedeutet das genau und wir sind die
abstufungen nach denen dann gewisse
massnahmen ergriffen werden ja so die
eine inzidenz geht die andere kommt die
infektions inzidenz also die infektion
die wir haben die positiven corona tests
auf 100000 einwohner in den vergangenen
sieben tagen die wir bislang alle kennen
das verschwindet erstmal das spielt
jetzt keine rolle mehr das ist sehr
wichtig dass hatten zahlreiche experten
seit monaten schon kritisiert bild hat
er das auch immer wieder kritisiert die
ganz normale incidents in die wir uns
alle gewöhnt haben dieser gilt jetzt
keine rolle mehr jetzt gibt es eine neue
instanz aber die hospitalisierung
incidents eben die schaut darauf wie
viele menschen sind in den vergangenen
sieben tagen pro 100000 einwohner
gerechnet ins krankenhaus gekommen also
ähnlich gerechnet nur dass es eben nicht
um infektionen geht sondern um schwere
verläufe schwere fälle die im
krankenhaus landen und da gibt es
sozusagen drei warnstufen ab der ersten
stufe ab eine hospitalisierung incidents
von 3 dann soll flächendeckend in einem
bundesland zweig gelten also dann kommen
nur noch geimpfte und genesene menschen
in die gastronomie rhein zum friseur und
so weiter und so fort dann ab einer
zweiten stufe ab einer inzidenz
hospitalisierung sin city dance von 6
gilt zweig plus das heißt dann auch dann
kommen nur noch geimpfte und gelesene
irgendwo rein aber die müssen sich auch
zusätzlich einmal testen lassen und ab
eine hospitalisierung incidents vom 9
das ist die dritte warnstufe dann werden
weitergehende maßnahmen ergriffen das
hört sich erstmal schwammig an ist es
auch das haben die länder nicht klar
ausformuliert das kann also jedes
bundesland für sich selbst entscheiden
aber es läuft ab dieser dritten
warnstufe ab dem hospitalisierung
incidence wert 9 auf teil lag bei uns
hinaus super erklärt noch besser wäre es
gewesen wenn es einfacher gewesen wäre
und man es gar nicht so schwierig hätte
erklären müssen wir gucken noch einmal
ganz kurz gemeinsam rein in dieses
papier wir haben es ihnen hier einmal
auf unseren großen screen geschickt also
das ist der beschluss von heute diese
zehn seiten die sich die kanzlerin heute
mit den ministerpräsidenten gemeinsam
ausgedacht hat harte streitigkeiten
darüber aber dann eben doch nach rund
fünf stunden hat man es geschafft dieses
papier zu einigen und ich war einmal
runter hier auf punkt 8 da sie hier geht
es vor allen dingen erst mal um es eben
schon wie kann man jetzt schneller
boostern in deutschland gibt es nicht so
richtig einigung wie geht das eigentlich
dürfen apotheker in zukunft auch im nein
das steht hier noch nicht drin das hat
man noch nicht geschafft das fest zu
legen damit man tatsächlich 27 millionen
booster impfung hinlegt sowie die
kanzlerin das will und fordert und
ankündigt man weiß auch noch nicht wann
die impfpflicht dann eigentlich greift
in alten und pflegeheimen die kommt
nämlich ganz genau so wie in
krankenhäusern 3g am arbeitsplatz das
ist hier der absatz 5 der für sie alle
zu hause wenn sie beschäftigt sind gilt
ab montag und ich fahre noch mal runter
hier geht es dann um 3g in bussen und
bahnen das lief ja schon in dieser woche
rauf und runter verkehrsminister scheuer
hat schon gesagt ist so gar nicht zu
kontrollieren und so weit kommt aber
halt trotzdem will jeder von den
ministerpräsidenten unklar wie das
kontrolliert werden soll es gibt auf
jeden fall bußgelder da steht da auch
noch drin und jetzt wie gesagt hier
punkt nummer 8 und hier kommt philippe
piatti wieder ins spiel denn es geht um
diese besonderen maßnahmen also wann
gibt es noch striktere coroner regeln
und wo eigentlich und da gibt es diese
schwellenwerte ja schwellenwert steht
hier drin und ihr leben steht das wort
hospitalisierung skate also ein wert der
bemisst wie voll die krankenhäuser sind
und wenn dieser schwellenwert 3 eben
erreicht ist philipp dann greift diese
erste schwelle dann wird verschärft ab
da geh' zweig und jetzt will natürlich
jeder in deutschland wissen bin ich da
betroffen oder nicht kannst du ganz
groben überblick geben wo diese
schwellenwerte schon erreicht sind
aktuell ja also die unterschiede sind
sehr sehr groß tatsächlich zwischen den
ländern wer sich ganz detailliert für
jedes bundesland informieren möchte kann
das jetzt gerade auf bild de tun diese
grenzwerte bestimmen unser leben ein
großartiger artikel der das alles fein
auf dröselt jedem einen überblick
verschafft wo was geht und wie gesagt
die unterschiede zwischen den ländern
sind wahnsinnig groß es gibt länder wie
schleswig holstein wie niedersachsen ich
glaube die sind sogar noch unter dem
ersten schwellenwert unter 3 bayern
liegt gerade knapp von 9 also knapp vor
dem dritten incidents wert ab dem dann
fast eigentlich schon teil locker uns
gelten müssen und dann gibt es
bundesländer wie beispielsweise
thüringen die liegen schon bei über 15
also die müssten zumindest nach diesem
beschluss in den teil lockdown gehen
aber wie gesagt wahnsinnig große
unterschiede ähnlich wie bei der ganz
normalen inzidenz da sieht man ja auch
bayern sachsen thüringen ist extrem weit
oben niedersachsen schleswig holstein
liegt eigentlich noch in einem
akzeptablen bereich dass also das was
für uns alle das leben ganz anders
gestalten wird jeder muss jetzt schauen
wie es in seinem bundesland um die
hospitalisierung rate steht man kann
natürlich davon ausgehen in ländern mit
hohem ins identen ist wahrscheinlich
auch die zahl derer die ins krankenhaus
müssen auch entsprechend höher dennoch
kann man das auch nicht immer gleich
setzen dass es keine rechnung die quasi
eins zu eins funktioniert jetzt schauen
wir weiter auf das was in der zukunft
kommt dann läuten dezember heißt es ja
wird man gleich wieder zusammengekommen
weil du da gibt es dann einen neuen
stufen plan könnte sich die zauberkugel
reinschauen aber man kann zumindest
sagen was könnte uns da erwarten was
gibt es überhaupt noch vor
eskalationsstufen die wir da noch
greifen können ja also dieser neunte
dezember der ist hier auf der letzten
seite festgehalten ich kann das hier
einmal zeigen der neunzehnte punkt das
ist ein wirklich ein ganz großes
politikum das ist das ergebnis eines
riesigen politik krimis und zwar gibt es
da unterschiedliche deutungen die union
also die ganzen unionsgeführten
bundesländer haben gesagt wir werden
diesem gampel gesetz morgen im bundesrat
nur dann zustimmen wenn uns die ampel
versichert dass wir am 19 dezember noch
einmal zusammenkommen um das
infektionsschutzgesetz eventuell neu zu
beraten und noch mal an zu schärfen wenn
es das pandemie geschehen erforderlich
macht also damit hat die union die ampel
ein bisschen erpresst die ampel hingegen
sagt dass es für uns überhaupt kein
problem natürlich muss man gesetze
jederzeit neu auswerten wenn sich neue
lage ergeben die ampel sagt nämlich die
union hat das nur rein geschrieben damit
sie morgen ohne gesichtsverlust diesem
gesetz zustimmen kann aber ja paul
ronzheimer hat das schon getwittert das
hört sich an nach salami lockdown das
kennen wir auch aus dem vergangenen
winter wo man erst ein locker und leid
beschlossen hat und dann nach geschäft
hat genauso könnte das hier sein und du
bist ja nicht nur bild zahlen chef
sondern du willst bis bild meinung chef
philipp und du hast dazu auch eine sehr
stabile meinung was da heute passiert
ist man hat das ja in der
pressekonferenz gemerkt vize kanzler
noch vizekanzler olaf scholz der fand
das jetzt erst mal ausreichend davon
dass auch deswegen offenbar ausreichend
weil im moment der christian lindner mit
der fdp ans bein gebunden ist und
daneben sitzt die kanzlerin die auf der
pressekonferenz sagt für mich reicht das
hier heute nicht aus ich trage das mit
liebe freunde aber alles was passiert in
den nächsten wochen das habt ihr zu
verantworten die ampel und genauso sagt
der markus söder gerade in dem ton den
wir gesehen haben der verschärft jetzt
ordentlich in bayern und sagt aber naja
freunde also das was ihr da heute
verabschiedet hat ich finde das nicht
ausreichend ihr müsst jetzt am 9
dezember beschließen ob das okay war
oder ob ihr hier kräftig überfüllte
intensivstationen möglicherweise tote in
deutschland verantwortet liebe ampel tja
also ehrlich gesagt zu markus söder
markus söder kann bis zum 15 dezember
tun und lassen was er möchte denn bis
dahin gelten die aktuellen verordnung
noch also markus söder hätte vor wochen
schon in ein lokal in einen kompletten
locker und gehen können wenn er das für
richtig gehalten hätte er hat das glaube
ich vor allem aus politischen gründen
nicht getan er will ja nicht der einzige
sein der sich die blöße gibt und einen
lock down verhängt aber das war ehrlich
gesagt ein ziemlicher flop bis zum 5
dezember kann markus söder in seinem
bundesland tun und lassen was er möchte
das kann ihn komplett egal sein was
irgendwo in schleswig-holstein los ist
den bayern hilft das überhaupt nicht
wenn die menschen in bremen in hamburg
in schleswig holstein oder niedersachsen
2g oder 3g haben markus söder ist
ministerpräsident von bayern er kann
alle maßnahmen ergreifen bis zum 15
dezember kann er tun und lassen was er
möchte er kann schulschließungen
anordnen kann ausgangssperren an ordner
da kann die gastro komplett zu machen
dafür ist er verantwortlich und niemand
sonst nicht olaf scholz nicht christian
lindner sondern nur markus söder jetzt
hat man sich ja auch besonders in die
haare bekommen das hat markus söder auch
eben gerade in seiner pressekonferenz
noch einmal gesagt was die verlängerung
der epidemischen lage im land betrifft
er ist die union ja ganz ganz shade und
sagt wir schauen uns die zahlen an und
können nicht verstehen es wurden auch
begriffe wie es ist absurd genannt dass
man die epidemische lage die jetzt am 25
november ausläuft nicht verlängert wie
geht es in dieser entwicklung weiter tja
also die epidemische lage läuft jetzt
erst mal aus und klar das klingt auch
total absurd deswegen betont markus
söder das ja auch er weiß er ganz genau
was bei den menschen ankommt deswegen
sollten wir das auch wirklich noch
einmal besprechen wenn die epidemische
lage ausläuft klingt das für den
normalbürger erstmal so die ampel
erklärt die pandemie für beendet wie
kann sie das machen die inzidenz und
steigen doch die krankenhäuser werden
verloren da kommt die ihre ampel und
lässt jetzt die epidemische lage
auslaufen das ist aber falsch die
epidemische lage ist nur eine rechtliche
grundlage die rechtliche grundlage für
extrem scharfe massnahmen maßnahmen die
wir in deutschland auch nicht mehr haben
möchte die falsch sind wir möchten nicht
dass menschen nicht mehr aus dem haus
gehen dürfen wir möchten nicht dass
ausgangssperren verhängt werden wir
möchten auch nicht dass flächendeckend
schulen geschlossen werden das ist schon
einmal passiert nicht nur einmal leider
in deutschland sondern immer wieder und
das ist falsch und das ist gut dass es
sehr gut dass die ampel das verbietet
dass das nicht mehr möglich ist die
ampel bietet aber zahlreiche weitere
instrumente auf die kann markus söder
dann auch nach dem 15 dezember zu
greifen wir haben es ja jetzt gerade
alles besprochen zwei g2 g + 3g im öpnv
also das ist ja wirklich da sind
strengste eingriffe da kann man doch
nicht sagen dass das alles zu locker ist
ich meine worüber sprechen wir zweig
flächen in einem bundesland heißt dass
ungeimpfte menschen nicht mehr ins
restaurant dürfen nicht mehr zum friseur
dürfen man kann ja sagen das ist richtig
die menschen verdienen das ganz egal wie
man dazu steht es ist eine sehr strenge
maßnahme und einfach zu sagen ja das
reicht nicht nur weil mir die
ausgangssperren und die schulschließung
weggenommen wurden entschuldigung das
kann man nicht ernst nehmen